the harmony international choir is
rehearsing these young singers are
preparing a recital with vocal music
spanning five centuries under the
direction of Sweden's Fred sure Berg the
group which actually consists of five
choirs merge into one the individual
choirs come from Latvia the Philippines
Spain China and Germany
Papa buddy damper down don't you worry
and I will help you so I would go down
mm and we were I would like to have good
sound all the time there don't you the
crime has been rehearsing eight to ten
hours a day still the tension ahead of
the premiere is palpable eating together
in this school cafeteria is a chance to
relax the cuisine is German so how is it
on the bar Maya Erica Raphael and
Bernardo are all true professionals they
just can't seem to stop talking shop
when we're in the Philippines and we
study music like when we when we know
that this music came from this culture
this music came from this culture it's
really different when you actually get
to experience it firsthand let me see
the Portuguese music will activate and
music from that good folk music from
Latvia it's wow the world is not so
simple so there's so much to learn a
required has their own voices like
temper temper and and and it's hard to
mix the mix up everybody is like
reaching out and and then you hear when
Sabrina the new here when L top and some
baritone and it's not like mixing up but
no I think we are managing just fine we
have never worked these kind of pieces
so we are growing music in terms of
music and also growing in terms of
culture things like getting to know each
other in different cultures so yeah we
will take that this festival with us for
a long time whether it's organization
equipment or logistics festival director
[ __ ] Tama and her team had everything
under control they have to look after
400 students and plan 90 concerts Tama
has devoted herself to bringing young
people together with music for over two
decades
santi the system does actually most
challenging about it the individual
people are lovely to work with what can
pose difficulties is that they sometimes
have a different concept of time or they
need different food and require
different information in formats unit
but we all have to learn to cope with
that in our globalized world the
festival is around seventy percent
self-financing the entire city is
invited to attend the biota are bent by
hoyt night that gives local residents a
chance to enjoy the talent of their
international guests
the latvian choir is rehearsing one last
time in the courtyard the portuguese
fado choir is also putting on the final
touches to watch mickey
Oh God will be playing a lot of
traditional music in Portugal father
that we arranged it in our way passion
from Portugal
delicate notes from Turkmenistan
even the washrooms feature musical
experimentation and then the high point
of the evening the harmony international
choir
what did a fake hard bargainers say the
oldest loveliest and truest organ of
music is the human voice